I have to say um I make I'm a big
loyalist you know I I really am and I
love the royal family I love the world
the royal family just for our country
and and as a woman growing as a girl
growing up in Wales in Britain in the UK
I had my mom you know who was the
strongest most safest person to be but I
also had a queen
and you know sitting on the throne and
as I speak in Disney where queens and
princesses have become is the is the
topic du jour you know when you're
working with on a Disney project but a
woman who was really inspiration you
know a woman who made it okay with as a
woman prime minister when I'm in a
country that's never had a woman as a
prime minister and as a woman as a as a
figure of leadership of power but also
of um respect
um and so I should miss her dearly I I
like like I felt like I I lost a real
family member
um and I know that I'm the prince the
prince to Prince Charles Charles the
Third now King Charles III now will do
an exceptional job
um as well the family and supporting him
through a huge transition in his life
and um it's you know as God closes you
know a door somewhere he opens a window
you know and and that's what Britain is
we have a history and this is now
history you know moving on and the bats
on and being passed but I was I came to
call in my mother and FaceTiming my
family and going do you feel how I feel
and they went yeah it's a very it's the
most I don't know whether it's because
I'm British you know but I just felt
very
I get like a little bit a little piece
of me had gone gone and for me it's like
okay so I've never seen there never be a
queen
in my lifetime again
um I would imagine less I don't know but
anyway
um but it was it it was a very strange
feeling very homesick
very proud of my heritage